In theory you could take an output image and use gamma correction on it as a
post process. I mentioned that there's a problem with trying to gamma correct
if you have just eight bits per channel. Let's put a number on it, your job is
to figure out that number. Say we walk through all possible channel levels,
zero through 255 and gamma correct each value. Here's an example for an input
of one. There are few steps to convert a channel. First, if you convert to
floating point number by dividing by 255. Then use the gamma correction value
to raise it to a power. Convert back the range zero through 255, by multiply by
255. Then round the fraction to get the channel number. If the input is zero
this converts to zero on output. No surprises there. With one we jumped up to a
level of 21 on output. Level two jumps to 28. At these lower levels we have to
boost the output considerably to get the equivalent gamma corrected value for
display. Out of the first 29 output levels, zero through 28, we've used only
three. Already there are 26 levels out of 255 we'll never use. On the low end,
some levels are never used. On the high end, you can have the opposite. That a
number of different input levels map to a single output level. The question to
you is, how many unique output levels are there? I'm expecting an integer value
and it's clearly less than 256. Use whatever means you like to figure out this
answer, any programming language you like. This is an actual, real life
programming assignment. I personally wrote a little JavaScript program. I used
this bit of code to show me in the debug console, the answer it computed.